le sexe est-ce que c'est sale alors
attention qu'on soit bien d'accord on va
pas parler de la sexualité d'un point de
vue moral mais du point de vue de
l'hygiène mais bon si vous vous posiez
la question on va y répondre quand même
le sexe ce n'est pas ça voilà ça m'est
arrivé d'être dit mais donc la question
qu'on va se poser aujourd'hui c'est le
sexe est-ce que c'est sale mais surtout
comment on fait pour que ça soit pas
allez c'est parti
donc vous avez compris on va faire un
petit tour des questions d'hygiène en
matière de sexualité mais avant petit
message cette vidéo est sponsorisée par
Léo on travaille souvent ensemble ils
ont déjà sponsorisé plusieurs de mes
vidéos sur la sexualité et merci à eux
parce que c'est pas facile de parler de
ce genre de question par ici et
aujourd'hui comme d'habitude j'ai des
cadeaux pour vous les lots ils proposent
des sextoys de qualité vous savez ça
maintenant
comme le sauna 2 travel par exemple je
vous avais déjà montré le sauna Cruz bah
là c'est le même principe avec sa petite
tête là qui aspire c'est pulsations
douces etc sauf que le sauna 2 travel
c'est une invitation au voyage
l'idée c'est de pouvoir l'emporter
partout oui alors si vous avez mangé
chez votre mémé le sortez peut-être pas
quand même comme ça sans prévenir entre
la poire et le dessert mais sinon vous
pouvez glisser dans votre sac comme ça
et hop vu qu'il est tout petit attention
petit mais costaud il est aussi efficace
que le grand discret et puissant comme
un ninja
et sinon vous avez aussi la dernière
nouveauté huit modes différents trois
moteurs non c'est pas une voiture
c'est l'énigma wave avec sa triple
stimulation bon cette partie là vous la
connaissez c'est la même technologie à
base d'onde Sonic et de vibrations que
le sauna le toy pas le bain vapeur et
celle-là vous vous doutez mais attendez
cette partie là elle fonctionne avec la
technologie wavemotion c'est à dire que
vous avez compris les cadeaux maintenant
allez les cadeaux d'abord je vais vous
faire gagner un sauna 2 travel et un
énigma wave voilà comment ça va se
passer dans les commentaires vous
écrivez
exactement comme ça avec la bonne
orthographe et moi je tire deux
personnes au sort et elle reçoivent soit
le sauna de travel soit l'énigma way et
deuxième cadeau le code DTC travel
jusqu'au 20 octobre 2023 je vous offre
25% de réduction chez les lots même sur
les articles qui sont déjà en Provence
mais pas sur les nouveautés ou la gaming
je vous mets le lien dans la description
n'oubliez pas le code DTC travel et hop
bon voyage bon on va commencer par la
base à savoir nos organes génitaux et
puis on rentrera petit à petit dans le
vif du sujet calmez-vous c'est à dire
les trucs à faire et les trucs à ne pas
faire quand nos organes génitaux entre
en contact les uns avec les autres mais
bon déjà d'où ça vient cette idée que le
sexe est sale c'est des jolies
dégueulasse les organes génitaux c'est
pas propre l'odeur déjà
nos organes génitaux ils ont une odeur
toutes les parties de notre corps ont
une odeur d'ailleurs une odeur plus ou
moins discrète selon la partie du corps
en question et selon l'heure de la
journée aussi on va pas se mentir et
cette odeur pour schématiser elle est
liée à deux choses des trucs qu'on
fabrique nous-mêmes comme la sueur et
plein d'autres substances qu'on sécrètes
et des bactéries qui mangent ces trucs
qu'on fabrique justement les bactéries
elles sont comme nous quand elles
mangent elles rejettent des trucs et ça
sent voilà plus la partie du corps est
confinée pour reprendre un mot un peu
has-been plus il y a de plis plus il y a
d'humidité de chaleur etc plus il y a de
bactéries et plus elle se régale donc
plus ça sent normal tout ça a une odeur
ça sent un peu mais pas grand chose et
puis parfois en fin de journée bon bah
ça sent un peu plus mais bon une petite
douche et on en parle plus pour les
organes génitaux comme pour tout le
reste parce que des bactéries on en a
partout sur la peau dans le vagin dans
l'urètre dans les intestins dans la
bouche etc etc ça s'appelle le
microbiote les microbiote même et on en
a besoin pour vivre mais bon des fois ça
sent quand même un riz ça ferait trois
jours de grève
c'est pas une façon très élégante de le
dire mais c'est vrai que des fois ça
fait un peu même si on a une hygiène
irréprochable s'il fait chaud si on a
beaucoup transpiré si on a des vêtements
qui laissent pas bien respirer le
matériel si la douche ça fait déjà un
petit moment si la journée est bien
avancée bon dans l'optique d'un rapport
sexuel ça peut mettre mal à l'aise les
deux d'ailleurs
au moins alors on fait quoi pour éviter
ça d'abord si je peux me permettre ce
serait quand même vachement bien qu'on
se détendent un petit peu tout et tout
ça avec les odeurs corporelles plus ça
va plus on les cache et plus il y a du
parfum un peu partout dans les savons
dans les crèmes il y a des déos pour
sous les bras il y a des déos pour les
pieds il y a des déos intimes etc etc
déjà tous ces produits qu'on ajoute un
peu partout c'est pas bon pour la santé
mais en plus on est rentré dans un
cercle vicieux plus on cache notre odeur
plus on en a honte alors que bon un
corps en bonne santé en état de
fonctionnement normal et ben ça dégage
des odeurs voilà c'est pas la mort il
faut se calmer avec ça attention je dis
pas qu'il faut se négliger et qu'on s'en
fout je dis juste que si on se lave
comme il faut quand il faut et ben tout
ça c'est très gérable ça s'assume très
facilement mais bon on est d'accord là
on a dit qu'on était dans le cas où ça
sentait quand même un peu la
bouillabaisse pour les raisons que j'ai
expliqué plutôt ok là c'est pas pareil
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
commencer il y a de plus en plus de
marques qui proposent des lingettes
intimes par exemple bon déjà premier
truc si il y a un problème et que ça
sent pas bon vous allez pouvoir passer
autant de coups de lingettes banane
fruit de la passion que vous voulez ça
va pas régler le problème en plus ça
sentir la salade de fruits au gambas ça
va pas donner envie à grand monde le
cocktail de crevettes dans la première
chose à faire c'est de regarder un petit
peu ce qui se passe au niveau de votre
microbiote par exemple et puis s'il y a
une infection ou un problème bah de
soigner ça donc ça veut dire aller chez
le médecin mais même s'il y a pas
vraiment un problème que c'est juste que
la douche commence à remonter il y a
quelques heures et que voilà et ben les
lingettes c'est vraiment vraiment pas
l'idéal quand même non plus bah ouais le
problème c'est leur composition
là-dedans il y a plein de produits qui
peuvent être soit irritants soit causer
des allergies et qui peuvent même
déséquilibrer le microbiote donc
favoriser les infections donc les odeurs
etc etc donc c'est quand même un peu
causé un problème en essayant de le
résoudre oui et puis dernier problème
les lingettes là ça laisse quand même la
zone un petit peu humide et qui dit
humidité dit risque de développement de
bactéries donc bon il y a des lingettes
que vous pouvez trouver en pharmacie
mais l'idéal ça reste quand même de
faire ça à l'ancienne de nettoyer à
l'eau et au salon un savon doux parce
que c'est de la muqueuse tout ça bon
c'est fragile puis il faut pas
déséquilibrer le pH et on oublie le gant
de toilette ça c'est un nid à microbes
des mains propres c'est très très bien
pour faire ça ah oui et alors petit
rappel on nettoie l'extérieur mais pas
l'intérieur ça c'est valable pour tous
les orifices de notre corps à part la
bouche là allez-y Franco s'il vous plaît
vaginales c'est non les bains de vapeur
c'est non sauf si vous avez installé une
ruche là-dedans mais c'est pas conseillé
les goupillons pour biberons c'est non
de toute façon personne fait ça ah bah
non personne bon vous avez compris bien
nettoyer la surface c'est parfait allez
farfouiller plus loin là c'est jamais
une bonne idée d'ailleurs l'intérieur le
corps le lave tout seul on a une
fonction auto nettoyante on a des
sécrétions qu'on fabrique nous-mêmes
pour évacuer les trucs qu'il faut
évacuer c'est valable pour les oreilles
c'est valable pour le nez et au niveau
des organes génitaux bah ça donne ces
trucs là que vous avez peut-être déjà vu
ça donne des pertes ça donne du fromage
ça s'appelle du smegma donc j'en profite
pour préciser les choses ces trucs là
c'est sécrétion ces petits machins
blanchâtre c'est normal donc ça veut pas
dire qu'on est sale c'est normal d'en
avoir bon après une fois qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu'on en avait il faut les
enlever surtout si on compte avoir un
rapport sexuel dans les minutes qui vont
venir donc petite toilette à l'eau
claire et au savon doux ou papier de
douche et hop faut se détendre avec les
odeurs corporelles mais il s'agit pas
non plus d'avoir de la salade grecque
dans le slip bon je vais pas m'étendre
plus là dessus je vous mets des liens
dans la description de la vidéo pour
tout ce qui concerne l'hygiène intime
les trucs à faire à pas faire les
sous-vêtements etc etc du coup il y a
des bactéries sur nos organes génitaux
donc c'est ça et ben non parce qu'on l'a
vu le microbiote toutes les bactéries
tous les microbes qu'on a là-dedans et
ailleurs et bah ça a un rôle bénéfique
donc c'est pas ça les deux seuls cas où
ça pose problème c'est quand il y a une
infection mais ça c'est pareil pour tout
un coude c'est pas sale mais un coup
d'infecté si bon bah pareil ou quand il
y a des bactéries qui se retrouvent aux
mauvais endroit et là pour être très
pragmatique je parle essentiellement de
bactéries fécales le caca un exemple
concret on a donc un microbiote
intestinal on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler il est composé de plein de
microbes différents qui sont très utiles
qui sont même indispensables au niveau
digestif comme des bactéries qui
s'appelle les échelles par exemple quand
elles sont dans leur environnement
naturel tout va bien mais si elle
déménage et qu'elle se retrouve dans une
vessie par exemple BIM cystite
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire pipi
après un rapport sexuel pour mettre un
coup de karcher dans les microbes qui
sont en train de remonter le long de
l'urètre l'urètre c'est le trou du pipi
c'est bien de le faire surtout si on a
une vulve parce que tous les orifices
sont très proches les uns des autres
déjà et puis l'urètre est beaucoup plus
court que celui d'un pénis donc les
bactéries arrivent beaucoup plus
facilement à remonter jusqu'à la vessie
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il faut s'essuyer
de l'avant vers l'arrière pour éviter de
ramener les germes de l'arrière vers
l'avant vous avez capté mais il y a pas
que les cystites s'il y a des germes
digestifs qui se retrouvent dans le
vagin c'est pas bon non plus donc
quelques conseils d'abord la
sacro-sainte règle pendant un rapport
sexuel quelque chose qui a été en
contact avec des germes intestinaux ne
va dans aucun autre orifice ensuite et
quand je dis qui a été en contact avec
des germes intestinaux je veux dire qui
a été dans le trou que ce soit un doigt
un pénis un sextoy une gerbille ou que
sais-je deuxième règle si on a quand
même envie de réutiliser quelque chose
qui a été en contact avec des germes
intestinaux on le lave avant voir on le
désinfecte et on le lave après aussi je
vais pas tout vous dire globalement se
laver après un rapport sexuel c'est
plutôt une bonne idée
troisième règle si vous vous servez de
votre sextoy de n'importe quelle manière
je veux pas tout savoir nettoyer le et
rangez-le s'il reste des sécrétions
dessus et qu'en plus vous le laissez
traîner un petit peu n'importe où il y a
des germes qui risquent de se développer
dessus et la fois d'après ça pourrait
vous combiner quatrième règle si on
utilise un préservatif sur un pénis sur
un sextoy ou autre on change de
préservatif quand on change d'orifice et
on change de préservatif quand on change
de partenaires et oui le préservatif non
parce que depuis tout à l'heure on parle
d'infection qui sont transmises par voie
sexuelle littéralement des infections
sexuellement transmissibles donc on va
quand même rappeler deux trucs
importants on fait des dépistages
réguliers même si on est en couple
exclusif et on met des préservatifs sauf
si on décide de s'en passer avec son ou
avec ça partenaire mais ça on en a déjà
parlé dans une autre vidéo je vous
invite à retourner la regarder un autre
truc donc je vous ai parlé aussi donc là
c'est pareil je vous mets le lien dans
la description vous retournerez voir
tout ça le sexe pendant les règles c'est
pas plus sale et pas plus dangereux que
le Alex en dehors des règles alors
attention on n'est pas obligé d'avoir
envie que ce soit d'un côté ou de
l'autre et évidemment il faut respecter
ça mais si ça attende tout le monde et
ben il suffit de prendre les mêmes
précautions que d'habitude ni plus ni
moins peut-être protéger la literie
aussi c'est pas mal et puis dernier
point important avant de se quitter la
lubrification quel rapport non parce que
des rapports sexuels avec une
lubrification insuffisante ça crée des
irritations des petites lésions voir des
blessures et tout ça c'est autant de
trucs qui peuvent potentiellement
s'infecter donc bien lubrifier c'est
aussi une question d'hygiène de respect
et de plaisir d'abord mais aussi
d'hygiène s'il y a un truc à retenir de
tout ça c'est le sexe c'est pas sale si
on fait les choses comme il faut
maintenant vous savez quoi faire donc
pas tout ça en fait ce que vous voulez
mais vous savez quoi faire quoi voilà
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
proprement et surtout portez-vous bien
[Musique]